la gran fiesta de la literatura
latinoamericana cierre sus puertas con
un balance positivo después de dos años
difíciles por culpa de la pandemia más
de 800.000 personas en total recorrieron
los pasillos de la Feria Internacional
del Libro de Guadalajara y su directora
saludó la energía desbordante que se
podía sentir en esta edición número 36
pero a la hora de despedirse la feria ya
está mirando hacia el próximo año Hace
unas horas asistimos a la sermonía de
pasación ceremonia de intercambio de
Estafeta entre el país invitado de honor
de este año y la delegación de la Unión
Europea que fue elegida para tomar el
relevo un desafío por lo que son 27
naciones que van a tener que
coordinación Mira nosotros ya tenemos
equipos en Bruselas y equipos aquí en
México y van a trabajar juntos y si es
un gran proyecto pero nosotros llevamos
65 años construyendo una Unión de
culturas dentro de la Unión Europea yo
mi equipo en Bruselas 20 nacionalidades
60 personas 20 nacionalidades entonces
eso es nuestro día a día de Buscar cómo
hacer algo en común paseado en la
riqueza de nuestra diversidad cultural y
la cita ya está hechada la próxima
edición de la feria internacional de
Guadalajara se realizará del 25 de
noviembre al 3 de diciembre de 2023